[Music]
that is jennifer lopez singing her hit
song jenny from the block at last year's
global citizen live event right here in
new york city the international advocacy
group has helped raise more than 62
billion dollars with a b for social
change since it was founded more than a
decade ago now their goal is to end
extreme poverty by 2030 this week global
citizen teamed up with hundreds of
celebrities activists and artists
including bill nye the science guy and
dakota johnson to host a two-day summit
i was asked to moderate one of the
panels and i said yes it was on gender
equality with gloria steinem listen that
panel pharrell williams and rouge aftab
a grammy-winning artist from pakistan
originally only on cbs morning global
citizen ceo and co-founder hugh evans
joins us now to bring us up to date good
to see you hugh evans always good to see
you thank you for having me i can
remember when you first proposed this
ten years ago and it just seems so pie
in the sky you look like you were 12
years old at the time
still does a little bit yeah he actually
does who is this guy but your enthusiasm
and your commitment and passion was so
infectious are you still on track to to
meet your goal of 2030 ending extreme
poverty
so i think there's there's good news and
there's bad news in the story of the
eradication of extreme poverty
the good news is that
in the last 30 years the proportion of
people living in extreme poverty has
plummeted from 52 of the world's
population in 1981 down to less than 12
percent of the world's population today
at the same time well the world's gross
income has quadrupled so we can afford
to eradicate extreme poverty the bad
news is that because of covert 19 100
million people have been pushed into
extreme poverty so the urgency of now is
more important than ever so what were
the engines that that helped people's
situation from 81 to just recently and
can you fire them again to help this 100
million people who have fallen back into
poverty you absolutely can so you need
to get access to health care and we saw
that during covert 19 but it's not just
one disease it's malaria tuberculosis
all of the communicable diseases need to
be addressed secondly we need to empower
girls and women because while there's no
silver bullet for the eradication of
extreme poverty the empowerment of girls
and women is the closest you're ever
going to get because women are far more
likely to invest back into their
communities and that's the power of that
and then thirdly we need to focus on
education because it's also one of the
closest tools that we have to enable
people to lift themselves out of poverty
global citizen published a strong letter
demanding these things from our world
leaders and businesses how would you
hope that this letter reaches them but
then also creates change and that they
do something right right right i think
to read it yeah but how is this going to
cause exactly absolutely well this year
as the g7 meets and also the g20 meets
later this year in bali we know that we
need leaders to step up on both the
eradication of extreme poverty and on
climate change right now one simple
thing that can happen is the u.s
congress has blocked what's called
special drawing rights
these are a financial instrument to help
enable the world's poorest nations to
have financial cash flow
we know that during the pandemic 17
trillion dollars was released for the
wealthy nations like our own
we need the poorest nations to have
access to capital yesterday mia motley
at our global citizen now summit the
prime minister of barbados stood with pr
with president uh prime minister trudeau
of canada and they both called for the
us congress to pass this measure it
should be a bipartisan measure you know
the thing is hugh when people hear
extreme poverty no offense their eyes
tend to glaze over for a lot of people
right that has never been the case for
you why do you feel so passionate about
this all this time i'm i'm fascinated by
how you work and the work you do and now
you're adding ghana to the list of
people that you're reaching out to well
the reason why i'm so passionate is it's
deeply personal for me i lived
in the philippines in india when i was a
kid and i saw the worst forms of human
suffering and i'm still in touch with
all the people that i live there and
i've seen how their lives sometimes have
improved but judah covert have been set
back and that's why this year for our
10th anniversary we're taking the global
citizen festival as you just said to
ghana west africa this year marks the
20th anniversary of the african union
and ghana's 65th anniversary of
independence from britain it's this
historic moment to unite the world
africa to america central park to black
star square in ghana west africa we're
going to bring the whole world together
this incredible hugh evans is always
honest to god trying to top himself with
what he does it's incredible you know
when you talk about that long-term
history of success the number of people
lifted out of extreme poverty i mean it
could be a headline in the papers every
day it's not because we tend to focus on
other things but there is progress it's
important to remember there is progress
and we can all take action right now
all right hugh evans thank you very much
thank you love it